is it the case that
the best poker players are the ones that
are able to at the right time
play really sub-optimally or really
um an orthod or unorthodox yeah
specifically there's one guy who last
year sort of took the poker World by
storm and his name is Michael Adamo and
he was doing things like I said you know
most of the top pros play very similarly
with the way that they you know
construct ranges and their bet sizing
and all these kind of things he was
doing some crazy things that nobody else
was doing so he studied you know sort of
a different form of Poker and it it was
unorthodox and it you know it throws
people off because he's in his comfort
zone with these bet sizes and different
things whereas everyone else they're
they're not well studied in those spots
so as a result of him being unorthodox
he became like a monster and very
difficult to play against because he
really knew what he was doing with it in
tournament or cash games it was
tournaments yeah he was crushing
tournaments he was going against the
norm in terms of what is like you know
this is what you should do as a poker
player in the spot he wasn't doing that
he was doing what he thought was best
and he was doing things outside the norm
that again in a vacuum you could look at
that and you go that that's incorrect
that he should not do that is a
clear-cut mistake even you know the
solvers or the computers or Game Theory
would say this is wrong what he's doing
but it's not wrong if he's doing it in a
way that he's exploiting other players
tendencies so for example with him say
he's playing far too aggressively okay
that's not good unless your opponents
are playing way too passively so if your
opponents are playing passively the
answer is to be more aggressive with
them and that's I think one of the you
know biggest advantages he had was he
was willing to do that
so in a spot where somebody would make
it a thousand he's he's making it 22
000. what what is this this makes no
sense and then people kind of know he
has nothing but they they're too afraid
to uh call him on it well and then
sometimes what happens is this is where
the leveling comes in you're like man
this guy's crazy he's bluffing like nuts
then he bets to 22 000. and you say ah
I'm taking my stand I call and then he
shows you like you know four of a kind
or something like that yeah so he gets
people out of their comfort zone and I
really enjoy watching him play he's
probably my favorite player to watch um
today watching a guy like that what
aspect of his play have you been able to
incorporate into your own like what do
you learn from that because you're
constantly learning you're constantly
adjusting yeah well no and I love it and
as I said so I think a lot of players
sort of come to the same conclusions
about this is how you play the spot but
he doesn't and I love watching and
thinking in terms of like why he's doing
this and one specific thing for example
is
he's willing to really go for it so in a
spot where let's say he bets 2 000 he
knows he'll get you call 2000 right
but he wants it all he wants it all so
he says you know what I'll give up the
2000 that's guaranteed and I'll bet 50
000. and maybe if you call that now you
know so listen you lose the two thousand
seven eight times but if I get called
before the 50 just once you know I'm
profiting from that and it also sets the
uh you know the template for you to
really sort of be a player that people
are afraid to play against he he knocked
me out in a tournament very early on in
a huge event and he had he was so far
ahead he was one step ahead of my
thought process in hand and he did
something that makes no sense whatsoever
I looked it up on the computer huge
mistake if you will but not a mistake
because he was taking advantage of my
tendency do you remember the cars is it
an example remember the whole thing yeah
I remember like this yesterday can you
take it like through an example hand
that really demonstrates it so I'll
explain the hand here so I uh I'm on the
button and I have Ace King which is a
very good hand and I raise and he calls
from the big blind
the Flop is nine seven five so I have
nothing really here he checks I check
behind the turn card's an ace
he checks I bet half the pot there were
six thousand there I bet three thousand
okay
now this is not a typical thing you see
people do but he raised me to 36 000.
massive raise bigger than the size of
the pot what was the Flop again so nine
seven five okay turn an ace what is he
representing exactly well he could have
a straight he could have three three of
a kind he could have you know aces up he
could have a whole bunch of hands so he
check raises to me big to thirty six
thousand I call the bet so now there's
something like 75 000. the river is a
five so the board pairs okay
he thinks for a while and he bets all of
it which is three times the pot he bets
two hundred and twenty five thousand
there's only 75 000 out there right and
in theory he should never ever have a
hand that can do that right so it
confused me and I was like okay well
this guy's aggressive he likes to Bluff
and all this kind of stuff so I made the
call with the Ace King and he turned
over six eight so he had a straight
but here's the thing in theory that
River card is bad for him when I call
the turn I have a lot of the time three
of a kind two pair that just made a full
house so he was risking that and the
reason he did it was because he thought
I would perceive him to be bluffing a
lot so he just went for it and it worked
he was able to double up right away and
knock me out of the tournament like an
hour in do you think he thought you
might fold like what I think specific I
think it was it came down to this it's
as simple as this
he was cognizant of His Image as being a
wild aggressive lover right and he was
fully taking advantage of me
knowing that my tendency in these spots
is to be curious and I want to call and
I want to see it so he was fully taking
advantage of the fact that he thought I
would call too often because otherwise
his play makes no sense a small bet a
medium-sized bet those make sense but
the bet that he made
in theory is indefensible it's just like
clearly a mistake but that's why poker's
so fascinating because he makes this
play and it wasn't a mistake it was
Above the Rim that's what it was do you
think he put you on Ace something I
think exactly what he thought I had was
Ace King or something like that you know
oh that is so fun that is so fun that
the two players at such a high level
were able to mess with each other's mind
how old is he's young he's in his 20s I
feel like that takes a lot of guts to uh
take risks like that well that's what's
great about him he certainly never
accused of not having the guts to put it
in and that's scary to play against
right the easiest opponent to play
against is one who's just
straightforward passive you know not
wild and crazy playing against him he's
going to put you in the blender as we
say